hey everyone today on the things we're
going to discuss what would have
happened if Olaf from frozen had been a
human instead of a sweet snowman who
likes warm hugs
we think this could have made for some
major differences in the frozen films
for instance could also and human Olaf
have fallen in love watch until the end
to find out what would Olaf look like as
a human we all know Olaf as a
happy-go-lucky snowman who likes warm
hugs and of course summer but what would
Olaf look like if you were to take on
human form YouTube user me I why art
kept all of Olaf's facial
characteristics even his nose looks like
a carrot well Australian artist Alicia
grig also known as spice twinkle pop
conceived Olaf as a sweet anime
character the deviant artist who goes by
Lane Eakins really captured Olaf's
hopeful eyes in her version of human
Olaf but the one that looks the most
like he could be in a Disney film next
to Anna and Elsa is human Olaf he has
warm eyes and a soft smile and let's
face it he's kind of dreaming it's easy
to imagine Olaf as a human when looking
at this uncanny art piece just as long
as he looks nowhere near this creepy
rendition of our lovable snowman
character this is the most terrifying
thing we've ever seen
seriously nightmare fuel for a week's
let's go back to the handsome Olaf from
rozelle DS version to wash that horrible
image out of our brains we can see this
guy being a loyal companion to Anna and
Elsa what would human Olaf's personality
be like as a snowman Olaf is an adorably
clueless bundle of snow who likes warm
hugs he's got all the qualities any
princess would want to have in a
hilarious sidekick he's sweet and
innocent outgoing and funny and almost
tragically optimistic although he is a
snowman he dreams and sings about
playing in the Summer Sun if it wasn't
for Elsa's snow cloud over his head he'd
be reduced to a hopeful little puddle
directors Chris buck and Jennifer Lee
wanted Olaf to have a childlike
innocence he is also a representation of
what happens when children make a
snowman for the first time
Jennifer Lee said that Olaf is the
physical embodiment of the love between
Elsa and Anna he doesn't seem to be
discouraged by obstacles whenever he
falls apart he just puts himself right
back together again
he can still smile even if he's being
impaled by a giant sword like icicle he
looks out for Anna and never leaves her
side even if it means that he will melt
in front of the fire king
some people are worth melting for what
do we learn about Olaf in the frozen
short films and frozen - well for one
olaf is perpetually hopeful he's not
afraid of an adventure in fact he
doesn't seem to be afraid of anything
he'll eat just about anything including
a fruitcake that goes right through him
he's a loyal friend to the end and he is
a master at unconditional love but he
does have his shortcomings it's clear
that if Olaf was a human he would need
schooling and frozen fever
Olaf admits that he can't read or spell
it seems there aren't many snowmen
schools in arendelle when he has to
rehang Ana's happy birthday banner
he puts the letters in the wrong order
instead of happy birthday it reads dry
banana hippy hat' that's an adorable
mistake for a snowman to make however it
would be worrisome for a human the same
age as Anna one thing we noticed is that
Olaf is an excellent older brother when
Elsa keep sneezing tiny snowman Olaf
hugs them calling them little brothers
he jumps right into the role of their
caretaker
he even brings them all the way to
Elsa's frozen castle to stay with
marshmallow the intimidating snow guard
from the first movie what a good older
brother how with Anna Elsa and Olaf
relationships be different if he were
human everyone knows that Olaf was born
from young Elsa's frozen magic we know
that he's a loyal friend who likes
adventure he's outgoing and optimistic
and doesn't seem to have any real
complaints but would some of that change
if he was dealing with the difficulties
that come with being human let's be real
here there are some problems that a tiny
floating snow cloud can't fix so would
be inhuman change
Olaf's relationship with Anna and Elsa
even though Elsa created Olaf when she
and Anna were just kids
Olaf hasn't changed much over the years
he's still childlike and full of wonder
so it's hard to say how old he would be
in human form what would he be like if
he had grown into a young man alongside
onon Elsa would he be a bit more of a
mischievous pal maybe he would be a
jokester who pranks the girls if he was
a human could it be
possible that Anna or Elsa would have
fallen in love with him
we know that honor can be a bit reckless
when it comes to love so anything is
possible let's explore that theory try
and focus here reasons why Anna might
have fallen in love with Olaf as a human
from the first frozen movie we know that
Anna can be a bit impulsive when it
comes to love when she meets Hans from
the Southern Isles
she sings one song with him and then
decides they should be married
thankfully Kristoff points out how
foolish that would be so how would Anna
have reacted to having a childhood
friends like Olaf in human form to grow
up with well for one thing she may not
have grown to become so impulsive if you
recall honor grew up in that giant
castle alone she couldn't be around Elsa
she was so lonely she started talking to
the paintings on the wall I mean a human
friend like Olaf could have curbed some
of her loneliness but would they have
just been really good friends or
something more it's clear that Olaf
would treat Anna with the love and
respect she deserves but with his
tendency to sacrifice himself for Anna
he might not last long as a human but
what if they were better as friends
after all love comes in many forms
whether it's romantic platonic or
between family members like Anna and
Elsa reasons why Anna would not fall in
love with human Olaf certainly not all
male and female characters and Disney
movies have to fall in love right that
was kind of the whole point to the end
of the movie frozen
it was Ana's act of true love for her
sister that saved Elsa and all of
arendelle but if Olaf were human maybe
he and Anna would just be good friends
since Olaf is super sweet with a
compassionate heart he might be
considered by some to be the friendzone
material that when you think about it
the term friendzone can be kind of
disrespectful according to a paper in
the Harvard Crimson friendship isn't
supposed to be an exchange of favors
it's supposed to be about the enjoyments
of each other's company it's not a real
friendship if you're just spending time
with someone because you expect
something in return
real friendship is not a means to an end
it's very likely that human Olaf would
be delighted at being just friends with
Anna because that's the kind of
character he is and his warm hugs don't
come with any strings attached
you won't get your new sled if she's
dead sometimes I really don't like you
what if Anna became a snow woman so what
if instead of Ana's heart or head being
accidentally frozen by Elsa's powers
she suffered a different side effect
from frozen fever we know that Elsa
creates a bunch of tiny snowmen when she
sneezes so what if she could
accidentally turn Anna into a snowman
with her untamed powers would honor be a
beautiful snow lady with angelic
features or would she look more like
Olaf with a giant oddly shaped head and
sticks for arms if Anna did become a
snow lady there's a chance she would be
having so much fun she wouldn't want to
return to her human form she could slide
around and play all day without having a
care in the world she wouldn't have to
worry about evil dudes like Hans she
could live in Elsa's ice castle with her
it makes sense since she wouldn't get
too chilled as a snow lady with all this
speculation of what Olaf would be like
as a human we definitely want to see
what she would look like as a snow woman
Olaf versus Kristoff who would on its
shoes okay if we have to have on a
romantically involved with a male
counterpart who would it be
she definitely forms a bond with
Kristoff in the original movie but as
his rock troll family admits he's a bit
of a fixer-upper and he's got a
borderline weird relationship with his
reindeer Sven Kristoff can be surly
smirky and a sarcastic while Olaf who
doesn't have a sarcastic bone or um
stick in his body
Olaf is all about Anna he told her she
was worth melting for out of all the
frozen characters Olaf seems to
understand true love better than anyone
then again it seems that Anna kind of
has a thing for bad boys her first crush
was on Hans and that guy was ruthless he
tried to attack Elsa and take over the
kingdom Kristoff is a step up from Hans
for sure but he still gives on a major
attitude sometimes and he can be kind of
gross so maybe Anna would prefer the
whole rugged mountain man thing over a
sweet squishy snow guy she seems like
she enjoys a heated argument every now
and then hang on you mean to tell me you
got engaged to someone you just met that
day what Elsa fall in love with Olaf if
he were a human if Olaf were human would
it be likely that he and Elsa
fall in love well first let's assume
that Elsa didn't create the human
version of Olaf because that would make
her his mom which would be totally weird
so instead let's pretend that Olaf is a
human who lives in arendelle or a prince
from a not so distant land it seems like
it would be hard for a guy to get to
know Elsa says she spent most of her
adolescence locked in her bedroom but if
he did we can foresee a major problem
with their love connection Elsa is all
about winter and snow and ice and Olaf
well he's clearly a summer guy he loves
the summer and everything that goes
along with it it's hard to imagine Elsa
and Olaf being compatible with this
major difference in season preferences
either Olaf would be bored and miserable
with the endless skiing vacations
courtesy of Elsa or Elsa would be
ruining their summer beach trips by
freezing and trying to walk on the ocean
water so would Elsa fall in love with
Olaf if you're human we'd say probably
not reasons Elsa would not fall in love
with human Olaf one big reason it may
never work between a human Olaf and Elsa
has to do with fans many fans believe
that Elsa is gay so therefore she would
have a female love interest rather than
a male one when frozen came out in 2013
the movie was celebrated for what some
fans perceived as Pro LGBTQ themes even
Elsa's hit song let it go is being
interpreted by some as a coming-out
anthem especially the part where Elsa
sings conceal don't feel don't let them
know well now they know let it go let it
go
fans even started a petition and
implored Disney with the hashtag hashtag
give Elsa a girlfriend
frozen tuesd co-director Jennifer Lee
responded to the fans requests for a
lesbian plotline saying they have had
tons of conversations about it she said
they are really conscientious about
these things Lee added that Elsa is
everyday telling the director where she
needs to go and that she will continue
to tell the filmmakers she said they
will have to see where they go with it
many think that Evan Rachel Wood will
play else's love interest as the autumn
e-type character we've seen in the
frozen 2 trailer we'll just have to wait
and see give this video a big thumbs up
if you think Olaf is the absolute cutest
be sure to subscribe so the things for
more videos like this one thanks for
watching we'll see you next time
[Music]